i don't know whether to laugh or to  scream npr reporting on new covid19  guidance from the cdc bullet point one  those exposed to the virus are no longer  required to quarantine i'm going to skip  number two for a second you'll see why  number three students can stay in class  after being exposed to the virus okay  number four it's no longer recommended  to screen those without symptoms okay  and then number two unvaccinated people  now have the same guidance as vaccinated  people  unvaccinated people  it's been two and a half years people  lost their jobs they said you have to  get it and if you won't you're going to  lose your job you can't go to school you  can't do never mind oops